Der absturz der sojus rakete bringt die raumfahrt ziemlich durcheinander nicht nur dass jetzt die hälfte der besatzung fehlt sondern auch der komplette plan
für die besetzung der crew auf der internationalen raumstation iss
kommt jetzt erst mal durcheinander und wichtige arbeiten bleiben liegen die forschung läuft nur mit halber kraft und
ungeklärt bleibt jetzt auch erst einmal das mysterium des loches in der sojus kapsel
klicks um science-fiction und am ende dieses videos habe ich noch eine hammer überraschung seid gespannt herzlich willkommen
Ja das war wirklich ein schock als die bilder um die welt gingen sie erinnerten an die größten katastrophen in der raumfahrt doch dieses mal
ging es für die besatzung der sojus-kapsel gott sei dank glimpflich aus niemand wurde verletzt
was bleibt ist ein riesiger finanzieller schaden und eine ungewisse zukunft der raumfahrt zurzeit weiß niemand
was da passiert ist und es stellt für die russische weltraumagentur roskosmos
eine absolute katastrophe
daraus kostenlos direktor dimitri rogosin wurde erst im mai ernannt um missstände beim tus programm zu
beseitigen und jetzt ist es noch viel schlimmer und zwar viel viel schlimmer nachdem in einer sojus-kapsel
ein loch gefunden wurde bei dem immer noch nicht klar ist ob es ein
produktionsfehler oder sabotage war kommt jetzt eine noch größere katastrophe
hinzu die russische technik um astronauten und astronauten in den weltraum zu bringen funktioniert
nicht zuverlässig dem dazu kommt dass es zurzeit aus der ganzen welt kein anderes zuverlässiges system gibt
um eben passagiere in den weltraum zu bringen lediglich china ist dazu in der lage aber mit dem kommunistischen land
arbeitet weltweit kaum jemand zusammen aber für den rest gilt weder die kapselform beugen die cst 100
starliner noch die crew drängen von spacex die sind bisher für raumflüge mit besatzung zugelassen
im juni 2009 10 soll die crew dragon zum ersten mal beim an staaten die cst von 100
starliner im august die frage ist jetzt wie schnell kann die ursache für das unglück gefunden werden
warum hat sich ein booster nicht richtig abgetrennt und die zweite stufe der sojus rakete beschädigt oder
schnell ist eine der neuen kapseln am start kann da irgendetwas
beschleunigt werden solange hier keine lösung gefunden worden ist wird die crew um den derzeitigen
kommandanten alexander gerst dort oben ausharren müssen ein trost ist
dass die versorgung mit nachschub weiterhin gesichert ist die vorräte an bord reichen auf jeden fall noch bis april wenn aber
das ist hier keine lösungen findet dann muss komplett neu geplant werden unter hochdruck müssen jetzt die neuen
kapseln in dienst gestellt werden bis dahin oder bis die sojus rakete wieder starten kann
läuft auf der ss alles im schneckentempo die besatzung ist jetzt mit drei leuten nur noch quasi halb so stark wie geplant und
wissenschaftliche experimente wenn jetzt zwar weiterhin abgearbeitet aber nur mit halbem tempo wichtige
außeneinsätze müssen jetzt erstmal entfallen das bedeutet auch dass das loch in der sojus kapsel nicht von außen inspiziert werden kann
es bleibt also erstmal weiterhin vollkommen unklar was da passiert ist weiterhin hängt die frage wie ein damokles schwert im raum war es
sabotage oder kaum weniger schlimm
schlamperei bei der produktion der kapsel alter zeigt auf jeden fall wie verletzlich die raumfahrtindustrie ist ein einziger unfall bringt alles durcheinander
gut dass sieben jahre nach dem letzten space shuttle flug 2011 endlich wieder neu
transportmittel ins weltall zur verfügung stehen und wahrscheinlich bald zum einsatz kommen wie wichtig die sind hat sich jetzt gezeigt es wird also spannend
was in den nächsten wochen und monaten geschieht ich bleibe dran so und jetzt heißt es
bescherung mein buch ja zumindest ein teil dieses buches aus dem rowohlt verlag
ist von mir ein geschenk ausgabe von
hawkings eine kurze geschichte der zeit mit einem sammelband mit gedanken über seine bedeutung mit artikeln von michio kaku
harald lesch reinhold beckmann und vielen anderen und mir
denken ohne grenzen und ja ich habe über die bedeutung von hawking als gewissen der menschheit der sich gedanken über künstliche intelligenz
die zerstörung unserer welt und aliens gemacht hat geschrieben ein super geschenk also
ein klick und zwar darauf und ihr könnt es
bestellen ja und hier geht es weiter drunter dafür auch draufklicken sabotage auf der internationalen raumstation iss
also nicht vergessen super buch draufklicken bis dann
bleibt dran